hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outpro and the mha manga
recently took a tragic turn and now we
are witnessing what could be the
ultimate Quirk Evolution as
shototogoroki arrives to face his
brother Dobby in the final fiery
Showdown all the todorokis are already
there to Bear witness to this explosive
conclusion although one mysterious woman
in the Philippines could change
everything I think horikoshi is cooking
something spectacular so let's get into
it you guys know how this works if you
enjoy our major content and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment right now it only takes
you a second but it helps us with that
YouTube algorithm and if you are one of
the over 50 of people who watch our
videos regularly but still haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a big
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications subscribing
on YouTube is of course completely free
but it helps me out a lot finally this
video will contain mha manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the last few chapters we
witnessed The Awakening of Dobby's
secret ice work The Quirk that he
inherited from his mother's side of the
family but which lay dormant inside of
him until now Dobby's mother Rey then
interrupted the battle between Endeavor
and Dobby she was followed by Dobby's
siblings fuumi anatsu who also arrived
on the Blazing Battlefield the entire
family is trying to convince Dobby to
calm down and go back to being Toya but
by coming so close to Dobby they are
also putting their own lives in direct
and immediate danger in fact their skin
is already getting scorched just from
being somewhat close to Dobby and the
Blazing Inferno that he has become the
only member of the Todoroki family who
is not there yet is of course Shoto but
we know that he's on his way and that
he's about to arrive at any moment
thanks to help he's currently getting
from he does Super Speed the latest
chapter starts off with Rey Natsu and
fuyumi all using their powerful ice
quirks to try to cool Dobby off and even
though the explosion is still Drawing
Near the rate of temperature increase at
the epicenter of the battle has gone
down that said the explosion still
appears to be unavoidable there doesn't
seem to be a way to actually stop it as
much as Dobby's family would like to and
speaking of Dobby's family we see that
Rey fumi and Natsu are trying their very
best to create as much ice as possible
but just their proximity to Dobby's
Inferno is continuing to Scorch their
skin making them suffer what will likely
be permanent damage although to be fair
that damage on their skin won't matter
much if Dobby really does explode and
they remain as close to the epicenter as
they are now when the explosion happens
if that explosion happens everyone
within a five kilometer radius will
perish instantly so yeah burns on their
skin will be be the last of their
concerns meanwhile as all of this is
happening Dobby is actually laughing out
loud and on the inside he is thinking
that for once everyone in his family is
actually looking at him for once in his
life he is the center of attention not
his brother Shoto not anyone else but
him Toya although in order to become the
center of attention he had to stop being
Toya and he had to become Dobby and
Dobby really seems to like this feeling
he likes being the center of his
family's attention even though he became
that center for the darkest and most
tragic reasons possible Dobby likes this
feeling so much that he wishes that he
got to experience it sooner we also have
to note at this point that endeavor
really isn't looking too hot or I guess
yes he is looking way too hot so that
was a bad phrase to use in this
particular situation but you know what I
mean Endeavor looks like his face is
literally falling apart from Dobby's
flames and Heat and these kinds of
panels really make you wonder if and
never can possibly survive this fight or
if he is about to go out in a blaze of
glory right along with Dobby a lot of
people think that endeavor's ultimate
Redemption will involve him sacrificing
his life but it's also clear that
horikoshi really loves Endeavor I mean
Endeavor is by far the best written
character in the series so who knows
maybe horikoshi will allow him to live
in the end we'll have to wait and see
the chapter then briefly switches Focus
to another battle which is a bit further
away from Dobby's Inferno but still
close enough to be within the blast
radius ochako and other heroes are still
battling toga in the twice clones like
yeah we knew that they were all there
and that this was going on but with
everything that's been happening with
Endeavor and Dobby I personally wasn't
focusing too much on ochako and toga no
offense but horikoshi wanted to remind
us that they are still out there and
with that in mind horikoshi wanted to
remind us that the heroes have a very
difficult task ahead of them the heroes
are attempting to evacuate both
themselves and all the civilians as far
away from Dobby as possible while still
having to deal with all those twice
clones at the same time this is
definitely not an easy task and one
wrong move could lead to them getting
overwhelmed by Sad Man's parade and
failing to evacuate on time nevertheless
the heroes are making progress and we
see that those UA robot vehicles are
successfully evacuating the civilians as
we speak that said as the evacuations
are happening both the civilians
themselves and everyone else in Japan is
able to witness the terror of Dobby's
Inferno thanks to the reporters who are
flying in a helicopter above the
battlefield the reporter are
broadcasting all of this live and it
must be a truly spectacular event to
witness on live television even though
the people watching can't exactly enjoy
it because they know that this is real
it's not a TV show for so many people in
Japan the consequences of this epic
battle and the other hero versus villain
battles that are going on right now will
determine their entire future and the
future of their country even in other
countries and especially in a cafe in
Manila Philippines people are watching
the battle live and there is one woman
with short white hair who is praying
quietly to me it seems clear that this
woman has a close personal attachment to
the events unfolding in Japan now maybe
horikoshi is just shouting out the
Philippines because he knows that
whenever you do that all your Filipino
fans will get hyped up about it and make
it go viral online but I tend to think
that this white-haired woman that is
deliberately being focused on is
actually relevant to the story in some
way but with that said huge Shout out to
all the Filipino fans of anime outpro or
out there the Philippines is actually
our third biggest country here on the
channel when it comes to demographics
right behind the U.S and India long
story short Filipinos clearly have great
taste and are men and women of culture
the chapter ends as our boy Shoto
finally arrives in goonga he hasn't
quite made contact with Dobby and the
others yet but he is almost there thanks
in large part to Eda when I was reading
this chapter for the first time I
thought that Ida was like a freaking
Transformer now and that he somehow
turned himself into an airplane in order
to get Shoto there as fast as possible
but it seems that the airplane is just
something that Shoto created with his
eyes in order to make them more
aerodynamic and allow them to travel
through the air more efficiently I have
no idea if this would actually work like
in terms of the laws of physics like
would a plane made of ice even be able
to fly I most certainly do not know but
hey it does look cool the ice plane then
disintegrate AIDS as Shoto begins to
activate phosphor his new super move
which we know has the power to
neutralize Dobby's heat and that is how
this chapter ends what a chapter
absolutely epic and intense from
beginning to end but here's the question
can a combination of shoto's phosphor
and the powerful ice quirks of Rey fumi
anatsu actually stop Dobby from
overheating and exploding or will they
maybe only manage to cool them off
briefly like for long enough to allow
them all to say their final goodbyes and
then Dobby inevitably dies but we get
some closure for the Todoroki family
what do you guys think can Dobby still
be saved somehow or is his death now
just a matter of when not if personally
I'm leaning towards Dobby actually dying
here if this was like Black Clover I'd
say nah he lives but with mha and with
how far gone Dobby seems to be yeah I
think he will die but after we get some
form of closure first for the todorokis
as for the other siblings and they I
think they survive but when it comes to
Endeavor it's more complicated is
endeavor about to die along with Dobby
as a way to finally redeem himself for
all his terrible mistakes and if he dies
who will replace him as the number one
Pro Hero Endeavor is another character
that I could totally see dying because
he's part of the old generation he made
many mistakes and him sacrificing his
life to make up for those mistakes would
make for an amazing character Arc but
okay let's say he dies who will replace
him as the world number one maybe
someone from the younger generation like
Meteo or even Deku are we gonna see a
generational shift before the manga ends
or is it still too soon for that let me
know what you think down in the comments
below I also want to talk about Shoto
and the evolution and Awakening of his
Quirk phosphor is obviously a big deal
but even the whole ice airplane thing is
a sign that shoto's work is continuing
to evolve rapidly Shoto knows that in
order to stop Dobby and make a
difference in this war he will have to
go above and beyond his current powers
and abilities and it seems that he is
really pushing himself to the edge and
this is allowing him to unlock new
aspects of his Quirk similarly to how
Dobby unlocked his ice Quirk after being
pushed up to the very edge of sanity and
then eventually over it with Dobby
already having stronger Flames than
Endeavor and now likely having an ice
Quirk that is even stronger than Rey's
he should theoretically be stronger than
Shoto so if Shoto hopes to fight back
and make a difference against Dobby he
will have to go beyond plus Ultra once
again Ken Shoto awakens some sort of
evolved form of phosphor that is
exponentially stronger than the earlier
version and that can actually cool Dobby
off by force could he awaken a totally
new and different aspect of his Quirk
something that goes even Beyond phosphor
maybe something like cold fusion that
gives him nuclear levels of power I'm
not sure what exactly horikoshi has
planned for for Shoto right now but I'm
sure that it's going to be absolutely
epic and of course with both Shoto and
Dobby experiencing recent Quirk
Awakenings I wonder what we can expect
from the Deku and shigaraki fight I mean
they're both already insanely strong but
could they also undergo further Quirk
Awakenings as they continue to push each
other Beyond every conceivable limit in
their final battle I still hope we're
gonna get to see Deku experience Quirk
Singularity which will lead to all of
his separate Quirk factors within one
for all merging into one single Godly
Quirk Factor the ultimate super Quirk
finally who was that woman with white
hair in the Philippines it's highly
unlikely that horikoshi would just show
her and focus in on her for no reason
right she has to be somehow important to
the story is she also a himura family
member who is related to the todorokis
through Rey is she going to do anything
else in the story or is she just gonna
stay the there and pray and I guess
drink coffee could she be someone we've
seen before like for example Eddie's
mother we know that Eddie's mother also
had white hair and we've actually seen
her in the anime but only from behind
could Eddie's mother be a himura don't
forget to drop your thoughts theories
and predictions down in the comments
below if you enjoyed this mha video and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like right now and if you're one
of the over 50 of people who watch my
videos regularly but haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a big big
favor right now and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys